for somebody who's looking at the
young universe at the early universe
and are talking about god and our
agnostic
who do you think is god
so i thought you had just like one of
the best podcasts with sam harris this
past summer
and um one of the things i liked about
that conversation is he talked a lot
about happiness
and meditation
and he says something that's really
resonated with me and i've been working
around and trying to work on my own way
but he said like you can never
you can never be happy
you can only become happy
and i'm trying to take a little bit
further than that because i think it's
it's interesting like meditation is like
you're not like oh i'm happy and now
like oh my kid came in now i'm not happy
they're like no like you can be
satisfied kurt vonnegut said like so you
ever catch us sometimes alex you're like
walking around like life is freaking
amazing like i'm happy and kurt vonnegut
said you should say to yourself every
time that happens like a little mantra
like if this isn't goodness if this
isn't happiness nothing is just remind
yourself how awesome it is every breath
everything that you do when you make an
impact even some of the bad stuff that
happens good it's good so sam said that
and it made me think because i was like
well
what does it really mean
to to be happy uh because like i can
think of um i can think of about you
know two or three ways that right now i
could double my happiness
you know like when the lottery or
whatever like i could double my habit
there's only a few ways though right
like
you know i had uh um this this kind of
thought like how many boats can you
water ski behind like you had twice as
many followers now you got two million
followers five mil whatever it doesn't
do anything it's called the hedonic
treadmill like once you get to a certain
level it takes a lot more you know
change and followers money impact women
whatever you want to make you
have one more quanta of happiness right
on the other hand
this is a concept from entropy
i can make your life miserable in an
infinite number of ways in other words
there's more space space to make your
life unhappy than happy
and so i thought about that in the
context of what sam said about happiness
um so it's sort of like yeah it's an
expression of entropy
and that what you should be doing in
life
is doing that which
will cause you devastation
if it goes away
because those are the things that like
are where you're reducing
entropy like a kid like anyone who's a
parent
knows instantly what i'm talking about
like how to make your life
a billion times worse
but there's no way to make your life a
billion times better
and so thinking about that now turning
into the question of god's existence
i feel like there's no way that you can
believe in god
to quote misquote sam but there's ways
that you can become a believer in god in
other words you could increase the
bayesian confidence level that there is
some and let's not call it god because
that's a freighted term let's just call
it some infinite source of goodness or
our beautiful power in the universe
right
simple things can do that you can
increase your credulity in the goodness
of life and we have this bias as humans
towards negativity negativity bias
well-known fact
so what i want to do is is let's call
god good right that's where it comes
from god good same words in german
and
when we think about what is good let's
do those things
that would devastate us
and a lot of that could be relationships
and there's a powerful concept from
um from network theory which is that you
know the number of connections in a
network you know i'm just saying if
you're on it it grows as the square of
the elements in the matrix in the number
right so you think of a matrix with n
people you know person one two three
four and then there's four other people
there's 16 different pairs but two half
of them overlap the diagonal is where
you know each other you know yourself so
there's but that still grows as n
squared
so those connections
increase
and decrease right you ever have two
friends that are fighting and like
you're kind of upset even though you're
not fighting with either one of them so
like a network grows like that so you
want to increase your network as much as
possible but only the kind of high
quality interstices between them and i
think in doing so you incr you make
yourself fragile not antifragile and i
think that is where
purpose and maybe approaching some
notion of god can come from
so that is a source of meaning
maximizing the goodness in life and the
way you know is good is if it's taken
away it would devastate you
that's one way
think about your brand your business
your spouse your kids
i mean parents can't contact i've known
parents that have
jim simons here's a perfect example he's
one of my oldest friends and mentors
he is one of the richest people on earth
gulfstream mega yacht this is all
documented books about
um
he lost two sons as adults
and i hear people say oh i'm so jealous
of jim simons
would you take everything
i don't know where he has that strength
and his wife marilyn
and his first wife barbara
i'm not i'm not like that
some people are there are angels that
walk among us
and
you know i there's this famous prayer
it's like you know uh god you know
there's there's an old saying that like
one of the hardest tests there are in
life is to be given a lot of money and
you see it like happens with like lawyer
like people who win the lottery or
whatever or nfl football players after
their career is over they get they're
broke right and i always like god please
test me with money you know that'd be
great but but in reality you should
never say i'm gonna
i want what x person has unless you're
willing to take everything and you'll
find you won't want to take everything
you